je m'appelle barbara je suis parolière
musicienne chanteuse
on est en nombre ce soir on est venu
conquérir lyon ensemble et ce sont trois
mots qui ont l'air très très chouette et
qu'ils le sont mais pour pouvoir
l'affirmer comme ça devant vous ce soir
il m'a fallu passer par pas mal
d'épreuves et c'est ce que je suis venu
vous raconter quand j'avais 12 ans
j'aurais tellement aimé qu'on me dise
t'inquiète pas c'était mauvais à l'école
c'est pas un drame
il ya plein d'autres possibilités dans
la vie quand j'avais 15 ans j'aurais
tellement aimé qu'on me dise que tout
est possible
so lu ment tout qu'on n'est pas obligé
de devenir ce que les autres attendent
de nous quand j'avais 18 ans au moment
de choisir mon futur sur apb cette
merveilleuse plateforme
j'aurais adoré qu'on me dise ok barbara
respire de quoi toi tu aurais envie
j'avais 18 ans donc je ne savais pas et
je pensais même pas à la possibilité de
devenir musicienne parce que ça me
semble être complètement absurde
alors j'ai choisi la facilité le chemin
un peu tracé par la famille les attentes
et je suis allé en fac de droit
alors je vais être très honnête c'est
très compliqué mais a priori pas
impossible de devenir une grande avocate
quand on passe son temps à redoubler
donc je regardais tous mes amis réussir
et passer les épreuves passer les
épreuves et je me disais mais mais
qu'est-ce-qui visons que moi je n'ai pas
le problème c'est que à force de me
poser cette question je me suis mise
dans la comparaison avec les autres
alors puis ils réussissent
plus je me dévaloriser et plus je me
dévalorise plus je me sens seule
et dans cette solitude je peux pas
m'empêcher de ressasser cette question
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont que moi je
n'ai pas à ce moment de ma vie je j'ai
la raison d'un côté qui me dit t'as pas
le choix il faut que tu es un diplôme
une preuve de ses capacités
il faut que tu continue dans cette voie
et le coeur qui me dit oh ça suffit
arrêtes tu vois bien que là c'est trop
l'enfer c'est pas grave
réfléchis de quoi toi tu aurais envie
heureusement j'ai la chance d'avoir une
meilleure amie formidable qui s'appelle
carmen et qui face à tous ses
bouillonnements existentielle m'a dit
mais arrête ton délire t chanteuse
depuis toujours moi j'ai toujours su il
ya que toi qu'il voit pas en fait donc
vas-y et seysses et maintenant voilà
j'ai fini non je rigole ça a été ça a
été le premier déclic de ma vie en fait
ce qui est fou c'est qu'elle a ouvert en
moi des possibilités des nouvelles
possibilités un champ de d'infini
incroyable j'avais 21 ans et j'étais
chanteuse dans ma tête
maintenant il fallait que je le mette en
pratique et que je le devienne dans la
réalité alors je vous laisse imaginer
quand on s'ouvre je joue pas aux jeux
vidéo vous jouez je sais pas si vous
jouez au jeu vidéo mais en fait ça mais
je crois que quand on débloque des
mondes dans les jeux vidéo on est tous
contents parce qu'on se dit oui plein de
trucs que je connais pas c'est la folie
et où ben moi j'ai ressenti ça je me
suis dit waouh vient de débloquer des
trucs de fou en moi tout est possible
devant moi donc je commence à écrire mes
premières chansons j'écris mes premiers
clips
je rencontre plein de gens c'est la
folie je vais en studio c'est incroyable
aller en studio je découvre ma voix je
me dis wow incroyable et puis je me
souviens très bien un jour où j'étais
c'est un plant j'étais derrière mon
ordinateur sur facebook et je me dis ça
y est faut que je me prouve que je suis
chanteuse alors je vais inviter tous mes
amis a aimé ma page
là c'est très gênant parce que parce que
passer voilà essayé inviter vos amis à
vous aimez vous verrez ce que ça fait
c'est très bizarre et bref six mois
après avoir commencé la musique je signe
dans un label et alors là je me dis ça y
est c'est fini demain je suis céline
dion all by myself tout ça tout ça
évidemment ça se passe pas du tout comme
ça et tant mieux
mes petits démons reviennent comme ça je
sautais à l'oreille mais tu te rends
compte
qu'est ce que tu fous là t'es
complètement illégitime il ya une erreur
de casting c'est pas possible
et à nouveau je me mets dans la
comparaison avec les autres
qu'est ce que tous ces musiciens que je
trouve incroyable et qui évolue autour
de moi mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont que moi
je n'ai pas qu'est ce que je fous là
vraiment moi dont le la seule qualité
semble être ma voix et dont j'étais à
priori même pas vraiment sur comment
m'affirmer comment trouver ma place en
tant que femme en tant qu'auteur en tant
que compositrice dans un monde de
manager reconnu de compositeur populaire
de maison disque un monde très masculin
alors
j'ai pas j'ai pas trouvé tout de suite
la réponse à ma question de légitimité
cette quête de sens de ma valeur a
provoqué trois rencontres des rencontres
qui ont été assez cruel même
bouleversante mais je crois que c'est
elle qui m'ont permis d'être la femme
que je suis aujourd'hui donc je partais
de très loin en terme de confiance en
moi dans la vie j'avais donc pas de
diplôme en musée que je sais pas lire
une partition le clé de sol je connais
pas femmes bref voilà c'est pratique
pour être musicienne et est donc je
n'avais aucune qualification et je
j'allais voir les gens et je disais mais
je suis auteur ah bon et décrit quoi et
pour qui
non mais je vous jure je suis musicienne
je compose je fais de la musique j'ai
envie de faire mes chansons ah non non
non mais tu sais tu t'es très mignonne
tu ferais mieux de s'inquiète pas on va
t'envoyer des trucs on va trouver des
gens pour faire tes chansons non mais je
vous jure en plus j'ai plein d'idées
j'ai envie de décrire mes clips de les
réaliser
non toujours pas toujours pas non tu tu
vas rester là sagement tu vas attendre
et à vrai dire j'étais contente de ça
parce que je me disais c'est tellement
improbable que moi je sois ici dans cet
environnement que je laissais faire je
laissais les autres avoir un avis en
fait sur mon projet sur ce projet qui
allait être à destination d'un public
donc c'est quelque chose de vrai c'est
quelque chose qu'on doit défendre
forcément quand on passe son temps à se
dévaloriser sa laisse place à beaucoup
de dérives parmi elles harcèlement moral
violences psychologiques violence
verbale rabaissement
je sais pas si ça vous est déjà arrivé
d'entendre à longueur de journée c'est
grâce à moi que tu es là sans moi t'es
rien j'étais créer c'est assez difficile
à entendre et à ingérer d'autant plus
quand ça vient de la part de personnes à
qui j'ai accorder ma confiance comme
s'ils me dévaloriser ça allait les
dévaloriser eux et en même temps je
voyais pas ce que je pouvais faire
d'autre qu accorder ma confiance à ces
personnes parce que j'étais tellement
convaincus de leur supériorité
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance parce que
j'ai été entouré de très belles
personnes de très belles âmes qui m'ont
permis d'ouvrir les yeux j'ouvre les
yeux et je comprends que j'ai plus
jamais envie de laisser personne me
parler ou s'adresser à moi avec violence
je décide de ne plus avoir peur
je comprends que pour avoir mieux il
faut provoquer les choses ça veut dire
travailler ça veut dire faire les choses
par soi même se faire confiance et ne
pas laisser les autres nous remplir de
leurs rêves leurs attentes leurs
projections provoquer c'est accepter
d'être moi en fait simplement moi mais
c'est déjà tellement énorme
c'est accepté de m'écouter de prendre
des décisions qui peuvent peut-être
menées sur des erreurs et c'est pas
grave je rebondis c'est accepter mes
états d'âme accepté d'être moi vraiment
et simplement
finalement je crois que j'ai réussi à
devenir ma propre guide et à arrêter de
constamment cherché la validation dans
le regard de l'autre
parce que cette place que je laissais à
l'autre ce besoin que j'avais de me
sentir validé je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui est très ancré en nous vous
faites dans la société
en tout cas moi en tant que femme je
ressentais le besoin ultime d'être
validé par les hommes
alors il faut évidemment en vouloir à
personne
j'appelle juste à ce qu'on en prenne
peut être conscience et qu'on apprenne
tous et toutes à déplacer notre gars
qu'on devienne porter et pas réducteur d
autres parce qu'on peut tous être ces
personnes là personne n'est exclu d'être
le manipulateur la manipulatrice de
quelqu'un petite parenthèse mais qui a
son importance
à chaque fois qu'on a projeté sur moi
des choses qu'on m'a mis des vêtements
qui m'allait pas du tout c'était le
regarder c'était la vie en fait des
hommes sur ce que j'étais et chaque fois
que j'ai pris conscience et que j'ai
réussi à me libérer de l'emprise c'était
au travers de la parole et du regard de
femme bienveillante
parce qu'en fait vraiment c'est ça dont
il s'agit c'est de se libérer de
l'emprise d'hommes de pouvoir et dont
nous je crois que je crois que c'est en
chacun de nous on a cette potentialité
de nous porter de libérer la parole des
femmes parce que la parole des hommes
allaient déjà libéré mes hommes et
femmes nous avons le devoir de grandir
ensemble
c'est quelque chose qui doit se faire en
communion paradoxalement je reviens sur
ma petite histoire quand j'ai réussi à
me libérer de l'emprise de ces personnes
ça n'a pas été la teuf tout de suite
j'ai d'abord été très très seul je me
suis senti en tout cas très très seul
j'avais l'impression que j'avais plus
aucun repère et en fait je me suis rendu
compte qu'il me restait qu'une seule
option est que cette option c'était de
me faire confiance
c'était de me poser des questions
simples et de répondre par des réponses
simples qui je suis quelle est la
musique que j'aime qu'elle est la
musique que je veux faire quels sont les
histoires que j'ai envie de raconter
qu'elle est mon histoire
je sais pas si ça vous est déjà arrivé
mais moi ce que j'ai ressenti déjà
arrivé d'être sous l'emprise dans ma
phrase ce n'est pas terminé dans ma tête
c'est très étrange
donc je ne sais pas si ça vous est déjà
arrivé les deux reprises mais moi à ce
moment là j'ai compris qu'il faut qu'il
allait falloir que je fasse preuve de
beaucoup de courage et en fait dans ma
tête ça ressemblait vraiment à une
grande falaise avec derrière le passé et
devant le futur mais qui ressemblaient
vraiment beaucoup à du vide et j'avais
très peur de me lancer dans ce vide de
sauter parce que parce que c'est
terrifiant en fait on sait pas ce qu'il
ya après mais bon j'ai sauté et il se
trouve que je vais bien regardez je suis
en vie je suis là c'est cool et surtout
je crois que sauter ça m'a permis d'être
beaucoup plus confiance en moi beaucoup
plus forte
beaucoup plus fier beaucoup plus
indépendante
aujourd'hui j'écris pour plein
d'artistes yannick noah chimène badi
julie zenatti black m j'écris mes clips
gelé coréalise je fais même mes habits
ça c'est mon t-shirt jeu très fière sa
première fois que le porte
s'il vous plaît dites moi qu'il est beau
après ça ça me fera plaisir
je sors un disque en janvier non on
février le 7 février
bref je suis plutôt plutôt très fier
très épanouie et surtout je me rends
compte d'un truc fou c'est que j'ai
cette même énergie à apprendre que
j'avais au tout début quand j'ai
commencé sauf que en plus de ça je suis
forte qui tout ce que j'ai compris c'est
incroyable et je me dis que si je tombe
bah c'est pas grave parce que je me suis
prouvé que j'avais les capacités de
rebondir en fait toute cette expérience
elle m'a permis de trouver la réponse à
ma grande question existentielle
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont que moi je n'ai pas
mariant parce que moi j'ai rien de plus
que quiconque
et parce que cette question est là juste
absolument absolument pas lieu d'être
j'ai je suis ce que je peux avec mes
erreurs
avec ma compréhension avec mon mes rêves
mon destin je crois que la petite fille
de 12 ans qui sommeil en moins là elles
sommeillent pas elle est en grosse teuf
à l'intérieur mais la petite fille de 12
ans qui est en teuf à l'intérieur de moi
elle est vraiment très très ému et très
fier d'avoir pu vous raconter cette
histoire pas du tout extraordinaire
d'ailleurs très très banal de femme
banale mais je crois que cette petite
fille ça lui prouve que je peux être
n'importe qui une femme une patronne
patronne de mon existence de mes désirs
de mes ambitions
j'ai le droit de faire des erreurs comme
dirait notre ami amel bent mais j'ai
droit aussi de réussir je peux être une
femme
tron une amie une amante
c'est une mère un jour et si j'ai une
fille lorsqu'elle aura 15 ans je dirais
que tout est possible
qui a pas d'ambition trop grande pas de
rêves trop petit qui lui faudra beaucoup
de travail beaucoup de volonté la
résilience qu'elle fera des erreurs et
devra se relever mais que toutes ces
choses pour arriver au bout de ses rêves
elle les a à l'intérieur d'elle parce
qu'on les a toutes et tous en nous et
mon enfant il pourra se regarder dans le
miroir et pourra dire je suis de la même
manière que moi ce soir devant vous je
peux affirmer je suis parolière
musicienne chanteuse
[Applaudissements]
vous
l'eau
[Musique]
j'avais ton âge y encore quelques pages
le passage à l'âge adulte et grisant
dans le virage devenir une femme ya pas
de stages pas de rattrapage je sais que
tu l'as pas décidé mais tu le portes cet
héritage à leur apprend à faire avec
rien n'est acquis vraiment mais n'oublie
pas d'être une femme avant d'être une
maman constatons arrière grand mère qui
pouvaient pas décider même pas divorcer
à peine respirer
t'es pas l'enfant gâté rien n'est jamais
gagné écoute j'ai pris quelques notes
petite folle sentiment d'être différente
du match pas dans les clous peut-être
toi qui as raison et les autres qui sont
après tout qui crée les codes et les
tabous qui a dit que ceux qui rentraient
pas dans le cadre de viendrait rien du
tout souvent les futurs génie sont
mauvaises à l'école est souvent celle
plus timides qui deviennent des idoles
alors en classe ces professeurs de casse
teddy bonne à rien l'ouvreur pas trop ou
alors on vous l'a bien s'inquiète pas
des pics n'inquiète pas que des grosses
l'épopée du collège sont les premières à
douarnenez cassis regarde pas les autres
leurs conseils à la con on est con ce
que dit le coeur et l'a souvent aidé à
prendre un thé mais toi tu es quelqu'un
de spécial c'est suffisant
[Musique]
les petits bonheurs ta vie sont souvent
le plus cool chanter céline dion elle
rappelé on verra ça tu défends courtois
bien de gens qui t'aiment regarde
seulement ceux qui te donne et penser
qu'ils te prennent petit à petit tu as
du temps petit petit prend de l'élan la
virtu ne construirons pas besoin
d'entraînement
tu monteras des projets qui casseront la
figure mais relève toi trouve une
échelle et escalade les murs tu veux
devenir patronne alors devient patronne
de la personne te dire que tu es pas
assez bonne sait jamais ce qu'ils
foutent rien qui arrive au sommet ne
compare pas aux autres ça c'est un quoi
déprimer
tu sais y'a pas de limites même pas de
temps les seules limites sont les
regrets ctera d'avoir dit pas mal
[Musique]
écoute pas les ragots te mêle pas des
histoires
la vérité c'est que les choses ne seront
jamais toutes blanches noires la vérité
c'est aussi que la vie ne sera pas
toujours rose
c'est toujours des mauvais mais qui
tombe amoureuse du c'est le genre de mec
qui te rend malheureuse
[Musique]
s'il te full black faudra que tu te
fasse la malle s'il te touche alors que
tu veux pas faire un pas que tu trouves
ça normal
l'amour et la violence ne font pas bon
ménage surtout laisse rien passer
pour ne pas tomber dans l'engrenage n'y
a pas d'exception pas d' excuses
sexuelle mito une fois deux fois trois
fois
n'attends pas celle de trop témoin
confiance et en parlant qu'on commence à
guérir
fais moi confiance et en parlant qu'on
commence à guérir y'a pas que les gestes
qu'ils feront des dégâts les motos comme
des balles qui resteront bloqués en toi
laisse personne croire que c'est à cause
que tu as mérité la violence stop
l'influencent quelle qu'elle soit déjà
toxiques qui évolueront près de toi tu
es trop fort tu es trop belle trop
importante
tu es trop forte trop belle trop
importante tu es trop forte tu es trop
belle trop importante
merci
[Applaudissements]